الحمد لله ثم الحمد
لله ما توفيقي ولا اعتصامي ولا ثقتي الا
بالله عليه توكلت واليه انيب حسبي
الله احمده تعالى حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا حمدا يليق بجلال وجهه وكمال صفاته
وعظيم سلطانه
يا ربنا لا نحصي ثناء
عليك انت كما اثنيت على
نفسك واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك
له له الملك وله
الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان حبيبنا وعظيمنا وقائدنا
شفيعنا محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف
الغمه تركنا على المحجه البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا
هالك صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه
اجمعين اخص
بالذكر ابي بكر
الصديق وعمر
الفاروق وعثمان ذي
النورين وعلي
الكراو
والبطين الحسن
والحسين وعن عمي النبي الكريمين
حمزه
والعباس وعن ازواج النبي الطاهرات من
الادناس
والارج اخص
بالذكر
الصديقه بنت
الصديق ام
المؤمنين عائشه رضي الله
عنها ورضي الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن بنات النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
زينب
ورقيه وام
كلثوم وفاطمه الزهراء
البتولي ورضي الله سبحانه
وتعالى عن السته
البرره الذين هم تمام العشره
المبشره وعن بقيه الصحابه والقرابه
والتابعين ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم الدين
رضوان الله تبارك وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين في عباد
الله اوصيكم ونفسي المذنبه
الخاطئه بتقوى الله تعالى
وطاعته ولزوم اوامره وكثره مخافته اطيعوا
الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون ايها
المؤمنون واعلموا عباد الله ان تقوى شعار
المؤمنين ودثار
الصالحين ووصيه الله تعالى في وفيكم
اجمعين فقد قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى اعوذ بالله السميع العليم من
الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون صدق الله
العظيم اما
بعد ايها
المسلمون كما
تعلمون اننا نعيش اياما مباركه
عظيمه خلدها الله تبارك
وتعالى في كتابه
العزيز المنزل
على سيدنا
محمد النبي
الامي الذي لا ينطق عن
الهوى ان هو الا وحي
يوحى وهذه
الايام
تذكرنا بابي الانبياء ابراهيم عليه الصلاه
والسلام واختبار الله سبحانه وتعالى له
وهدايته
لذلك ساذكر لكم
اليوم قصه نبي نبي
الله
اسماعيل عليه السلام مع ابيه ابراهيم عليه
السلام مختصرا
احداثها كما ذكرها
ابن كثير رحمه الله تعالى بتصرف يسير
مني ايها
المؤمنون اعيروني
اسماعكم
وقلوبكم لدقائق
نعيش
معها مع هذين النبيين الكريمين
عليهما الصلاه
والسلام سال ابراهيم عليه الصلاه
والسلام الذريه الصالحه
الطيبه وان الله سبحانه
وتعالى استجاب
له وبشره
بذلك قال تعالى
وبشرناه بغلام
حليم
وانه لما كان
لابراهيم عليه
السلام ببلاد بيت المقدس 20
سنه قالت
ساره زوج ابراهيم عليه
السلام لابراهيم
ان ربي قد احرمني
الولد فادخل على
امتي وتقصد
هاجر فادخل على امتي
هذه لعل الله يرزقني منها
ولدا فلما وهبتها
له دخل بها ابراهيم عليه السلام
وحين دخل
بها حملت
منه فلما حملت
هاجر ارتفعت
نفسها وتعاظمت على
سيدتها فغارت منها
ساره فشكت ذلك الى
ابراهيم فقال ابراهيم
لساره افعلي بها ما
شئت فخافت
هاجر
فهربت فنزلت عند عين
هناك وفي تلك
اللحظات جاءها ملك من
الملائكه وقال
لها لا تخافي
فان الله جاعل من هذا الغلام الذي حملت
خيرا ثم امرها بالرجوع
وبشرها انها ستلد
ولدا
وتسميه
اسماعيل ويكون وحش
الناس يده على
الكل ويد الكل به
ويملك جميع
البلاد
اخوته
فشكرت فشكرت الله عز وجل على
ذلك يقول العلماء من اهل
التفسير وهذه
البشاره ان من طبقت على ولده محمد صلوات
الله وسلامه
عليه
فانه الذي به سادت
العرب وملكت جميع البلاد غربا
وشرقا واتاها الله من العلم النافع والعمل
الصالح ما لم يؤتى امه من الامم
قبلهم
هذه هذه امه محمد عليه الصلاه
والسلام وما
ذاك الا بشرف
رسولها على سائر
الرسل وببركه
رسالته ويمن
سفارته وكماله فيما جاء به وعموم
بعثته لجميع اهل الارض
ولما رجعت
هاجر وضعت اسماعيل عليه
السلام
وولدته لابراهيم من
العمر
86 86
سنه قبل مولد اسحاق عليه السلام بث3 عش
سنه
ولما
ولد اسماعيل عليه
السلام اوحى الله سبحانه وتعالى الى
ابراهيم يبشره باسحاق من
ساره فخر
لله
ساجدا وقال له قد استجيبت قد استجبت لك في
اسما
وباركت عليه وكثرته ونميت جدا
كثيرا وان هاجر عليها
السلام لما ولد لها
اسماعيل اشتدت غيره سار
منها وطلبت من الخليل عليه السلام ان يغيب
وجهها عنها
فذهب بها
وبولد فسار
بهما حتى
وضعهما حيث مكه
اليوم
ويقال ان ولدها كان اذاك
رضيعا ثم جاء بها ابراهيم وبابنها اسماعيل
وهي
ترضعه حتى وضعها عند البيت عند
دوحه عند دوحه فوق زمزم في اعلى
المسجد
وليس وليس بمكه يومئذ احد وليس بها
ماء فوضعها هنالك
حتى فوضع
هنالك ووضع عندهما جرا فيه تمر وسقاء
وسقاء فيه
ماء ثم
قفى ابراهيم منطلقا فتبعته ام
اسماعيل
فقالت يا
ابراهيم اين تذهب
وتتركنا اين تذهب وتتركنا بهذا الوادي
الذي ليس به انيس ولا
شيء فقال قالت له ذلك
مرارا
وابراهيم لا يلتفت
اليها ثم قالت له
هاجر الله امرك
بهذا قال نعم
قالت
اذا لا
يضيعنا اذا لا يضيعنا ثم
رجعت فانطلق ابراهيم حتى اذا كان عند
الثنيه حيث لا يرونه استقبل بوجهه
البيت ثم
دعا بهؤلاء
الدعوات ورفع
يديه كما حدثنا القران
الكريم
ربنا اني
اسكنت من ذريتي بوا غير ذي
زرع عند بيتك
المحرم ربنا ليقيم
الصلاه فاجعل افئده فاجعل افئده من الناس
تهوي اليهم وارزقهم من الثمرات
لعلهم
يشكرون وجعلت ام
اسماعيل ترضع اسماعيل وتشرب من ذلك الماء
حتى اذا نفذ ما فيما ما في
السقاء
عطشت وعطش
ابنها
وجعلت تنظر اليه
يتلوى
فانطلقت كراهيه ان تنظر اليه وهو يتلوى من
العطش
والجوع فج فوجدت الصفا اقرب جبل في الارض
يليها
فقامت
عليه ثم استقبلت
الوادي تنظر هل ترى
احدا فلم ترى احدا الا
السراب
فهبطت من الصفا حتى اذا بلغت المروه فقامت
عليها ونظرت هل ترى
احدا فلم ترى احدا الا
السراب فعلت ذلك
سبع
مرات قال ابن عباس رضي الله
عنهما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فذلك
سعي الناس
بينهما اي بين الصفا
والمروه فلما اشرفت على المروه سمعت
صوتا فقالت لنفسها
صهم تريد
نفسها ثم
تسمعت فسمعت
ايضا
فقالت قد اسمعت ان كان عندك
غواث قد
اسمعت ان كان عندك
غواث فاذا هي
بالملك عند موضع زمزم
فبحث
بعقبه او قال
بجناحه حتى ظهر
الماء
فجعلت تح
تحوه وتقول
بيدها زم
زم وجعلت تغرف من الماء في قائه وهو
يفور بعدما
تغرف قال ابن عباس رضي رض الله عنهما قال
النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يرحم الله ام
اسماعيل لو تركت زمزم او قال لو لم تغرف
من الماء لكانت زمزم عينا
معينا قال
فشربت وارضعت
ولدها فقال لها
الملك لا تخاف
الضيعه لا تخافي
الضيعه فانها هنا بيتا لله يبنيه هذا
الغلام
وابوه وان الله لا يضيع
اهله وان الله لا يضيع
اهله فكانت كذلك حتى مرت بهم رفقه من
جرهم فنزلوا في اسفل لمكه فرا طائرا
عائف فقالوا ان هذا الطائر ليدور على
الماء لدنا بهذا الوادي وما فيه
ماء
فاقبلوا وام اسماعيل عند
الماء فقالوا اذنين لنا ان ننزل
عندك قالت
نعم ولكن
لا حق لكم في الماء عندنا قالوا
نعم فشب
اسماعيل وتعلم العربيه
منهم وانفسهم واعجبهم حين شب فلما
ادركت زوجوه امراه
منهم لا اريد ان اطيل عليكم ايها الاخوه
والاخوات
تابعوني في الجمعه القادمه ان شاء الله
بعد
العيد وسنكمل
هذهه
القصه
التي خلدها الله سبحانه
وتعالى اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله العظيم
لي ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين
ادعوا الله وانتم موقنون بالاجابه